bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
au parlement européen à bruxelles pour
une nouvelle édition d' europe hebdo et
dans cette émission grand reportage le
retour du plombier polonais point
d'interrogation détourné de son objectif
la directive européenne sur les
travailleurs détachés sert surtout à
recruter des salariés low cost ils
viennent d'europe centrale reportage à
cherbourg des salariés roumains sont
actuellement employés sur les chantiers
navals pour aider à la construction du
chalutier c'est tout à fait légal mais
ça fait hurler les syndicats les
entreprises profitent elles de cette
directive qui leur permet de faire
baisser leurs charges en toute légalité
paris est prêt au bras de fer avec
bruxelles halte au dumping social et à
la concurrence déloyale c'est le mot
d'ordre mais avant un tout autre sujet
pas si éloigné que le premier vous allez
le voir tollé à bruxelles après les
propos de david cameron sur
l'immigration en europe vous le savez
les travailleurs roumains et bulgares
pourront le mois prochain
travailler dans n'importe quel pays de
l'union européenne sans aucune
restriction à c'est réglo ce sont les
traiter c'est la fin de la période de
transition
ça fait peur au premier ministre
britannique
en janvier prochain elle c'est la fin de
cette temps de transition pour la
bulgarie et la roumanie
conséquence directe les travailleurs
bulgares et roumains pour au travail et
où ils le veulent dans le territoire de
l'union
sans aucune restriction neuf états dont
la france le royaume uni l'allemagne et
la belgique devront ouvrir leur marché
du travail notamment supprimant les
permis de travail à tous les citoyens
des deux pays y compris bien sûr aux
minorités roms c'est réglo c'est dans
les traités ces l'aiglon mais la
victoire on n'en veut pas il annonce que
la grande bretagne fera tout pour ne pas
donner envie aux immigrés d'europe
centrale de venir chez elle et cabrol de
sortir l'artillerie lourde
limitation des prestations chômage et
des allocations logement aux immigrés
d'europe centrale renvoi avec
interdiction de revenir pendant un an de
tous ceux qui ne sont pas là pour
travailler s'il m'en dit où dorment dans
la rue et pénalisation lourds des
employeurs qui ne verse pas le salaire
minimum
il y un contexte cameron parle sous la
pression du parti antieuropéen you keep
qui ne cesse de grimper dans les
intentions de vote
au royaume de sa majesté jamais
jusqu'ici un dirigeant européen avait
tenu de tels propos
la commission européenne a aussitôt
rappelé que la possibilité de vivre
travailler et étudier n'importe où dans
l'union et le droit que les européens
shellys le plus réaction malheureuse
excessive
cela risque de faire passer le royaume
uni pour le méchant pays au sein de
l'union européenne s'étrangle ton à
bruxelles la libre circulation n'est pas
négociable averti la commission un tollé
à bruxelles et voilà encore la question
de l'immigration qui met à rude épreuve
la cohésion entre l'est et l'ouest du
continent européen
alors nous avons été rejoint sur ce
plateau par cristian preda bonjour vous
êtes député roumain membre du ppe alors
on l'a vu dans ce petit reportage les
travailleurs roumains avec les bulgares
les polonais sont visés par les propos
de david cameron après la polémique sur
les roms la polémique sur les
travailleurs détachés maintenant cette
atteinte à la liberté de circuler ce que
vous ce que vous les roues mais vous
n'êtes pas les mal aimés de l'europe
on a parfois le sentiment que c'est
comme ça d'autant plus que vous voyez on
est maintenant à la fin d'une période de
transition où nous avons dû subir des
restrictions
c'est à dire qu'en donna à signer le
traité quand nous sommes entrés
on était d'accord que pour une durée de
sept ans et il y aider les sections et
certains pays sont allés jusqu'au bout
ah il ya neuf pays comme la com c'était
la plaie d'envoi de reportages qui ont
maintenues ces restrictions les autres
pays les ont déjà sublime est donc il ya
eu une vraie circulation un vrai
mouvement sur le marché du travail
mais non je comprends que david cameron
veut prolonger cette période c'est pas
possible du point de vue des traités
mais c'est quoi ce propos de david
cameron quoi la liberté de circuler
c'est pour tout le monde sauf pour les
roumains oui ça c'est bon voyez c'est un
peu c'est un peu absurde parce que
les roumains n'ont pas l'idée de faire
ça pour les britanniques et si on
entrait dans une telle logique c'est la
fin de l'europe si chacun commence à
dire je ferai une exception pour tel ou
tel pays
c'est absurde et puis permettez moi
d'ajouter c'est un peu absurde de mettre
face à face les ouvriers roumains les
ouviers bitani les ouviers belges et les
ouvriers bulgare les patronats abel jeu
les patrons à apollo net c'est l'europe
c'est pas la guerre de chacun au camp de
chacun c'est plutôt la solidarité c'est
plutôt la liberté
pour bien comprendre les craintes de
david cameron par rapport à
l'immigration venus d'europe centrale je
vous propose de l'écouter et vous
réagissez juste après
l'immigration et l'aide sociale de
l'état tout est lié
si vous allez dans nos usines vous allez
trouver la moitié des ouvriers qui
viennent de pologne de lituanie ou de
lettonie on ne peut pas leur en vouloir
ils viennent pour travailler il voit le
boulot il émigre ils font le boulot mais
notre responsabilité en tant qu'etat
c'est de dire non voilà notre
responsabilité c'est de dire non dit
david cameron mais t'as pas dire non ce
sont les traiter c'est c'est un discours
et autres addictions
oui mais c'est un discours qui vise
justement de l usage interne ou est de
chasser sur le terrain déjà occupé par
l'équipe et c'est ça le problème
à gambetta c'est qu'on a une force anti
européenne qui monte qui est d'ailleurs
très présente aussi au parlement
européen avec des discours radicaux et
donc l'idée c'est de chasser sur le
terrain de l'équipe
moi je trouve que c'est pas une bonne
solution et il y aura jamais assez
radical remettra en cause a traité oui
mais vous savez les électeurs préfèrent
toujours l'original à la copie donc
l'idée que c'est sont les conservateurs
qui feront plus avec des discours
radicaux interlope 1 qu'est ce que font
les vrais anti europe 1 c'est une
religion et chavannes kotaku ferme on
pensait qu'on pouvait monter le
populisme en encourageant ce jour nous a
manqué ce que ça va donner finalement
ils sont parlement ça va donner
plus de confusion plus de j'allais dire
de
de limitation des sentiments europe 1
cristian preda autre polémique
concernant les roumains ces travailleurs
détachés à la directive bolkestein
on en parle on en parle beaucoup un
exemple salaire moyen d'un travailleur
du bâtiment en france et 1400 euros par
mois les charges patronales pour un
français c'est 600 euros pour un romain
c'est 300 euros beaucoup de roumains qui
travaillent en france et les syndicats
crient au d'un pic sociale à la
concurrence déloyale vous entendez ce
cri là oui bien sûr on l'entend et puis
bon on a le sentiment qu'on a on a
renoncé à la fameuse formule du plombier
polonais pour trouver maintenant c'est
là le travailleurs détachés
c'est un peu la même histoire maintenant
je regarde les chiffres cvs qui a
beaucoup de travailleurs détachés en
france officiellement c'est dans
l'essence et le deuxième contingent
après la pologne
mais il ya aussi donc ça profite aux
français oui mais il ya aussi le même
chiffre de français qui travaillent
quant à veules des tâches à l'étranger
donc si vous voulez il ya un certain
équilibre qui se crée au niveau du
marché unique
il ya tant de français c'est ce
différentiel de 2 de charges patronales
qui inquiète
oui bon je vois si et je comprends
l'inquiétude des des syndicalistes
mais il faut aussi comprendre
l'inquiétude et j'oublie et qui chante
quand même dans une situation précaire
et qui sont obligés parfois de quitter
le pays et de travailler à l'étranger
c'est pas un boulot simple ça et c'est
pas une expérience facile à faire
quitter sa famille quitter ces lieux
pour travailler à l'étranger pour vivre
dans une sorte d' aller retour permanent
parce que la plupart des gens sont comme
ça ne s'est pas des gens qui
s'installent pour longtemps c'est des
gens qui qui qui font l'aller retour
pour des années des années c'est pas une
expérience s'il assumait donc je crois
qu'il faut vraiment prendre au sérieux
tout des expériences sociales en europe
pas seulement le fait que ici ou là il
ya des syndicats qui chante qui sont
n'est pas que les syndicats aient aussi
des tensions sociales et sur les deux
joues faut-il mettre maintenant en l1 et
faut-il mettre matériel les pas du
retour du plombier polonais maintenant
mais la question est celle ci la vraie
question politique
faut-il mettre maintenant en guerre les
patrons polonais et les patrons romain
les ouvriers belges et les ouvriers
belga est-ce que c'est comme ça qu'on va
résoudre le problème du de la classe en
arômes moi je trouve que tout on
comptait il faut encourager le marché
nique dans avec des messieurs libérale
non pas avec des réglementations qui
vont introduire d'éligibilité
supplémentaires et qu'ils vont bloquer
de nouveau le libre mouvement des
capitaux et des des personnes au niveau
de l'europe c'est ça mon point de vue
moi je trouve qu'il faut plus le
libéralisme la glamour essence elles
engagent un bras de fer avec bruxelles
ait pas d'accord du tout avec votre
position c'est que c'est quoi la
position de la roumanie parce que le
vote à la majorité qualifiée on se
demande avec qui vous voyez la roumanie
ce sera avec la grande bretagne dont la
gauchiste change pas la directive que ça
justement vous voyez le paradoxe et il
est ici parce que là dessus on est
d'accord avec kamal le même cameron qui
veut bloquer les roumains et les
bulgares donc nous je crois qu'on est
plutôt dans une
dans une perspective très collante on
veut plus de libéralisme et non pas plus
de réglementation et donc on croit que
limiter l'accès de certaines j'ouvrirai
kisha polonais roumains bulgares chez
contre l'europe et nous paradoxalement
on est plusieurs européens à l'est
maintenant qu'à l'ouest
on le voyait d'ailleurs d'ailleurs avoir
oublié un peu ces différences mais on la
retrouve avec plus de patients européens
à l'est qu'à l'ouest
on pourrait rajouter aussi que la
roumanie n'exporte pas seulement des
travailleurs bon marché mais aussi des
médecins qu'elle aimerait bien garder
donc merci en tout cas christian d'avoir
accepté notre notre invitation reste sur
ce sujet les travailleurs détachés en
place place aux reportages les chantiers
navals de cherbourg
or faire venir des travailleurs roumains
en toute légalité on l'a dit ça fait
débat c'est travailleurs coûte moins
cher du coup les syndicats s'inquiètent
pour l'emploi dans la région et c'est
assez rare pour être souligné un patron
a décidé de nous expliquer pourquoi il
avait recours à ces travailleurs
détachés vous allez voir ce sont ces
arguments sont assez compréhensible la
réalité n'est pas aussi simple qu'il n'y
paraît envoyé spécial à cherbourg en
normandie
elsa monde à gaza
cherbourg dans le département de la
manche
voici l'un des piliers du secteur naval
les cmn les constructions mécaniques de
normandie il y a quelques mois
l'entreprise était au ralenti
mais aujourd'hui elle tourne à plein
régime grâce à un contrat passé avec le
mozambique
une bouffée d'oxygène pour les cmn et
pour la ville l'assurance de près de
deux ans de travail pour 350 ouvriers
français et 16 intérimaire roumain des
travailleurs détachés qui exercent sur
le chantier en toute légalité
leur présence est permise par une
directive européenne
il bénéficie du salaire minimum français
mais les cotisations sociales sont payés
dans leur pays d'origine la roumanie
difficile d'évaluer le gain pour les cmn
l'entreprise a recours à une société
d'intérim roumaine mais l'économie
serait autour de 20% par rapport à des
salariés locaux pour la direction un
montage indispensable pour proposer un
prix attractif
wood très clair et tout à fait
transparent c'est pas pour augmenter la
rentabilité du contrat que nous avons
recours une partie de sous traitance
tels que telle que celle là c'est
simplement que si nous ne bâtissons
panneaux de bris pour faire offre aux
clients avec ce montage industriel nous
ne sommes pas compétitifs mais le
recours à ces travailleurs low cost a
suscité la polémique
il faut dire que le contrat a été
largement médiatisée à sa signature
le chef de l'état et des membres du
gouvernement s'étaient rendus au cmn en
saluant une victoire pour le made in
france
une publicité dont l'entreprise se
serait bien passé on avait fait deux
pages sur le contrat pour les cmn plus
la polémique a rebondi plus les gens
sont dit finalement ce contrat c'est
finalement pas aussi bénéfique que ce
qu'on avait espéré
et c'est plutôt cet aspect là en disant
ok c'est bien ça va sauver le ch et ça
va donner du travail aux chantiers
pendant deux ans on a
350 salariés pour le coût des locaux qui
vont avoir du travail pour deux ans
c'est bien et ils sont dit on nous a un
peu menti aujourd'hui les constructions
mécaniques de normandie aimerait être un
peu moins sous le feu des projecteurs
du côté des salariés discrétion totale
aucun ne s'exprime sur le sujet devant
une caméra pour mettre fin au débat
le directeur rappelle que la pratique du
détachement est largement utilisé par
ses concurrents et surtout qu'elle est
tout à fait légal le problème c'est de
changer les règles du jeu donc ça c'est
pas moi qui ai fixé les règles du jeu à
partir du moment où la concurrence les
utilisent les utilisent faute de quoi je
ne gagnerai plus de contrat cette
généralisation du détachement sous
couvert de la directive européenne
préoccupe les syndicats une position
délicate car s'il ne souhaite pas
interdire cette pratique
ils s'inquiètent de cette concurrence
déloyale et du message envoyé aux jeunes
de la région
aujourd'hui on en forme des jeunes
soudeur qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire
derrière
donc si on entend le discours des
patrons
je préfère prendre de la sous traitance
cost parce que ça nous coûte moins cher
donc ça sert à rien de former les jeunes
aujourd'hui
notre crainte elle est vraiment là c'est
à dire que effectivement ils sont
complètement dans la légalité mais sur
le bassin d'emploi on peut avoir des
craintes
le cas des cmn illustre la complexité du
détachement entre une europe économique
qui s'est mise en place et une europe
sociale qui se cherche
car au delà de ce dispositif la question
posée est celle des disparités sociales
entre les différents pays membres de
l'union
voilà c'est un reportage d'elsa monde un
gars va alors nous avons été rejoints
sur ce plateau par evelyne gebhardt
bonjour vous êtes eurodéputée allemande
social-démocrate et travailleurs
détachés c'est un dossier que vous
connaissez bien vos côtés constance le
gris bonjour vous êtes eurodéputée
française du ppe en france vous êtes
membre de l'ump
vous avez signé avec un collectif de
députés de sénateurs ump une tribune
dans la presse intitulé détachement des
travailleurs la faute de bruxelles alors
on met de voir ce reportage est un
patron qui dit moi j'utilise des
travailleurs détachés de roumanie parce
que la concurrence les utilisent si moi
je les utilise pas se gagne pas de
contrat est ce que vous entendez son
message
constance le grip j'entends parfaitement
ses messages je rappelle que la
directive détachement des travailleurs
qui date de 1996 et dont il est beaucoup
question aujourd'hui parce qu'il est
question de la retravailler de la
réviser d'en modifier à son des
conditions notamment d'applications est
une directive qui au départ est né pour
protéger les droits sociaux des
travailleurs mais qui repose sur l'un
des piliers fondamentaux de
l' aventure européenne et du marché
intérieur qui est la libre circulation à
l'intérieur de l'espace européenne
absents pas question de remettre en
cause ce principe fondateur de libre
circulation des travailleurs et de libre
prestation de services bien évidemment
au jour d'aujourd'hui dans une europe
élargie qui n'est plus celle de 96 avec
les différences notamment de charges
sociales qui pèsent sur les entreprises
on constate que ce principe de
détachement des travailleurs de libre
circulation des travailleurs subi des
détournements occasionne des fraudes des
malversations des défauts d'applications
qui eux sont tout à fait préjudiciable
n'diaye marcq l'allemagne aussi veut
modifier cette directive en effet depuis
le depuis très longtemps mon groupe
politique les socialistes européens
demandent une révision de la directive
une révision de fond pour répondre
justement ce inséré à ces questions de
fraude de malversations qui existe dans
ce domaine malheureusement la commission
européenne jusqu'à maintenant n'en
voulait pas et malheureusement nous
sommes minoritaires aussi au parlement
européen
donc il est difficile de le faire mais
il me semble qu'en feront uniquement de
la france et de l'allemagne pour
modifier cette 7e avec un certain nombre
de collègues du groupe ump peut-être
mais pas avec le groupe des
conservateurs du ppe
là nous avons un non clair de votre
compte politique
ici si vous travaillez avec nous là
d'accord on va arriver à faire changer
les choses mais en ce moment c'est très
très mal parti qu'est ce que vous
répondez à vis de gebhart alors je n'ai
pas la prétention ppe grande bretagne
pologne qui ne veulent pas
bouger et vous vous êtes membre du ppe
ou les sites et pétitions contre les
travailleurs détachés non ceci n'est pas
une pétition contre les travailleurs
détachés
j'ai simplement moi aussi regretté que
la commission européenne qui par la voix
de barroso s'était engagé dès 2009 a
porté une révision en profondeur de la
directive et le temps regarder et en
parler et sané corps mars 2012 donc
assez récemment que la commission est
venu avec une proposition nouvelle
moi aussi je regrette que la commission
ait tant tardé je pars un porte parole
du royaume uni ni même de mon groupe je
dis clairement en tant que députée
française ump engagé dans ma famille
politique je sais pour le maintien du
principe de libre circulation des
travailleurs pour le principe de
détachement des travailleurs dont je
rappelle que les travailleurs français
eux mêmes bénéfices il est bien
malheureux madame le gris que nous
n'ayons pas eu de majorité dans notre
commission parlementaire parce que tout
le ppe a voté contre l'ombre donc je me
demande vous parler comme ça en france
mais qu'est ce que vous faites ici au
parlement ou non est ce qu'on n'avait
pas voté avec moi si si si si je vais
voter sur sur bien des sujets tout à
fait conformément à mes préconisations
et à mes voeux une révision la directive
lorsque vous êtes contre tous pour la
révision de cette directive
alors comment fait concrètement pour
endiguer ce phénomène à l'ordre quand le
diane de ping social alors le dumping
social ça recouvre plusieurs réalités
d'abord il ya et ça ça ne dépend pas
rapport aux travailleurs détachés ya la
question de la disparité des charges
sociales - laurence les charges sociales
qui pèsent au prix sont très élevés
c'est vrai qu'elles sont plus élevés
qu'en bulgarie qu'en roumanie qu'en
pologne et même qu'en allemagne ça c'est
une question qui relève de la
responsabilité des autorités nationales
moi je milite dans une formation
politique en france l'ump qui
considèrent qu'il ya trop de charges
pesant sur les entreprises et qu'on a
fait que rajouter
depuis des mois et des mois plus de
tâches vous propose sur le plan européen
il ya des choses à faire il faut
renforcer l'arsenal législatif qui
permet de lutter contre les fraudes
contre les détournements contre les
contournements et là il ya des
instruments très précis qu'on peut
mettre en place plus de contrôle plus
d'échangé d'informations une liste noire
peut-être des entreprises et des sous
traitants qui s'arrange mal avec la
légalité d'accord justement je vous
propose d'écouter un chef d'entreprise
on l'a interpellé pendant notre
reportage et ils vous interpelle mais
d'amener les députés vous écouter vous
réagissez juste après
comment peut-on résoudre l'équation
économique
quand le même produit avec le même
niveau de qualité est faisable par de la
main d'oeuvre qui coûte entre 2 4 5 fois
moins cher que la nôtre
comment résoudre cette équation
économique il ya encore il ya beaucoup
de choses à faire au niveau européen et
surtout l'imposition par exemple des
entreprises dans les états membres est
très très diverses
elano états devraient faire un effort
pour enfin donner une solution sur ce
thème là l'allemagne est possible de ces
travailleurs détachés à vue dans les
abattoirs il travaille pour 3e 3e en
allemagne demandent aussi un smic en
allemagne qui n'existent pas d'ailleurs
avec la coalition que nous allons faire
je l'espère du moins ça va être mise en
place
enfin pour donner une réponse aussi
parce que nous ne trouverons nous ne
trouvons pas adéquat d'accepter ce
dumping social qui existe entre les
états membres qui existent aussi à
l'intérieur des éléments savannah béton
smit l'on parle de deux ans jusqu'en
2015 2017
pour commencer en 2015 ça va continuer
en 2017 mais on a déjà commencé
maintenant dans certains domaines et
nous en tant que socialiste nous allons
essayer de forcer la dose mais
évidemment le parti de madame merkel en
fait n'en veut pas donc il faut qu'on
s'arrange c'est pour ça il faut on va
mais on va faire aussi vite que possible
on sort le gris qu'est ce que vous dites
à ce patron la réponse apportée tout de
suite concrètement c'est de modifier son
toucher au principe fondamental de libre
circulation des travailleurs de toucher
aux modalités d'application de cette
directive est de lutter contre les
fraudes
le principe c'est bien que les
travailleurs détachés soit payé au
salaire du pays dans lequel ils
travaillent du pays d'accueil à leur
horreur voilà les conditions de travail
normales c'est à dire un nombre limité
de re par semaine le repos attendre de
droits sociaux
donc il est allé les cotisations les
faits dans le paysage social dans le
pays d'origine origine dans le pays où
est implantée l'entreprise
ça c'est effectivement le principe
auquel la question le choix parce que
pour moi
travailleurs du btp salaire mensuel 1400
euros moyens charges patronales en
france 600 euros charges patronales en
roumanie 300 euros le choix est fait
j'ai bien dit tout à l'heure que je
pense qu'en france de manière générale
nous avons une imposition et un poids de
charges sociales pesant sur les
entreprises trop élevé et maintenant la
question
concrètement demain c'est de travailler
et j'espère qu'on va y arriver qu'on va
coalisés à son nombre de pays pour mieux
appliquer la directive 96 qu'il faut
réviser qu'il faut renforcer qu'il faut
rendre plus opérationnels je dirais pour
lutter contre les fraudes contre les
détournements et de manière générale à
moyen et long terme
je milite pour à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne plus de convergence sociale
et de convergence fiscale pour
pacifiquement ne pas imaginer un jean de
serpents sociale et un serpent fiscal
vin qu'il veuille y à quelques décennies
un serpent monétaire au sein duquel
évoluerait avec des marges de plus en
plus réduite
les taux d'imposition et les taux de
charges sociales
il faut aller progressivement vers plus
de convergence sociale et de convergence
fiscale en europe c'est la logique du
marché intérieur européen c'est pourquoi
je milite tout à l'heure on a interrogé
un patron du chantier naval je vous
propose d'écouter maintenant un
syndicaliste de ce chantier naval à l'as
cherbourg
il est inquiet écoutez vous réussissez
juste après
à quand une europe sociale
à quand un véritable smic européen
on a parlé du smic en allemagne ils vous
demandent à celui qu européen à ce que
finalement le problème c'est qu'il n'y
ait pas un socle minimum des droits
sociaux en europe et à cela il faut que
nous y travaillons ça fait longtemps que
nous le voulons et nous devons faire
tous les efforts possibles pour pour le
pour le faire avancer
mais pour cela est sale cela je le dis
très clairement ici au parlement nous le
voulons au parlement européen
mais ceux qui sont contre en général ce
sont les états membres et surtout
certains états membres comme la grande
bretagne la pologne la tchéquie qui
disent non non non nous ne voulons pas
d'europe sociale en fait et c'est à cela
qu'il faut qu'on travaille et faire en
sorte que nous ayons des règles communes
il faut que nous allions enfin une
clause sociale dans les traités de
l'union européenne pour que cela puisse
vraiment mettre mise en place et à cela
nous y travaillons en ce moment et c'est
une des grands enjeux aussi des
élections que nous allons avoir au mois
de mai élections européennes pour dire
cela dépendra aussi des majorités que
nous avons ici au parlement européen
est-ce que nous allons y arriver est ce
que nous allons faire pousser cela dans
les états membres où est-ce que cela
reste comme cela qu est ce que vous
pensez que vous allez avoir une majorité
qualifiée là parce que sas de cette
révision de la révision de cette
directive ça va se décider là le 9 on va
commencer à négocier c'est des ministres
et conseillers des ministres que la
france elle va avoir une majorité
qualifiée avec l'allemagne où s'est
perdue l'allemagne en tous les cas va
changer de position maintenant puisque
dans le dans le traité de coalition nous
avons bien dit clairement que nous dit
que nous devons mettre l'accent sur les
droits sociaux justement dans le domaine
du détachement des travailleurs
donc la france le gouvernement français
ne va plus rester seul là dessus mais
bien pouvoir à vous trouver des alliés
là dedans alors j'espère bien que ça va
faire avancer
mais pour cela aussi il faut qu'au
parlement même nous ayons un soutien
plus fort constante la grille une
question politique pour terminer de
politique intérieure est ce qu'on
pensait que le front national va se
saisir cette question et que ça va aider
finalement les partis anti européens
je constate que le front national s'est
déjà saisi deux
cette question et sur ce sujet là comme
sur beaucoup d'autres profère des
contrevérités des mensonges des
approximations il milite purement et
simplement pour l'abrogation de la
directive détachement des travailleurs
et c'est sur ce sujet comme sur d'autres
il veut faire croire aux français qui a
qu'à faut qu'on y'a qu'à construire des
barrières
y'a qu'à supprimer la circulation des
travailleurs
il n'ya qu'à se protéger derrière des
frontier ce genre de polémique
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a d'ailleurs ça
fait monter les extrêmes et arrondies
leur ancien salarié ne le rappelle table
actuellement le cnca de résolution que
nous visions que ça n'aide pas de hier
matin que nous avons découvert le
problème il y a eu notamment au
parlement européen qui est souvent soit
bien des sujets très en avance très en
amont je dirais que les deux autres
institutions le conseil des ministres et
la commission
une vraie réflexion une vraie
mobilisation pour dire il y a des effets
pervers la dia était de 96 a été
détourné et nous voulons la modifier
nous voulons la renforcer notamment dans
l'objectif de lutter contre les fraudes
et notre but est de mieux travailler à
protéger les travailleurs les
travailleurs nationaux comme les
travailleurs détachés à pitre a déjà en
2009 nous avons demandé justement je
cherche ce changement de la directive
mais de dire non à la directive cela
veut dire dire non un certain nombre de
principes qui sont déjà sur la
protection des travailleurs et ça
enlèverait tout parce qu'on est là et ça
serait une catastrophe on l'aura bien
compris tout cas merci mesdames d'avoir
accepté notre invitation c'est la fin
d'europe hebdo merci de l'avoir suivi
restez avec nous sur les chaînes
parlementaires
là